if your earlier on time if your only
time you're late we're still learning
that process gonna be the hardest
working you know person you could be
that's how you separate yourself in the
competition
Stephan Curie point guard for the Golden
State Warriors in 27 years old I'm
blessed to be able to follow my dad's
footsteps and learn from his 16 year NBA
career you know hot hand himself on and
off the court I think I learned a lot
just by watching him how hard he worked
I'm gonna stopping here to put in and
prepare himself for a season and to do
that for 16 years it's kind of something
to be proud of winning a championship is
special and sometimes you want to you
know celebrate and be proud of because
it's so hard to do and not many guys and
then be a get to experience that but
there is more to life than basketball
and I've been a champion for another
Nets campaign and with the UN Foundation
for four years now taking the tour to
northwestern Tanzania and seeing
firsthand kind of the the impact that
malaria has on families in Africa to be
able to help those parents out and be
able to protect their families and I
think that's a great cause and we're
doing some great work it's a dream come
true to play basketball for a living and
a cherry on top of me was I was an MVP
something I dreamed about as a kid and
then you see yourself in the list with
other guys that have held that trophy
before the legends Hall of Famers
volaterrae champions it's a pretty
special feeling you know every game is a
new challenge you bring up on a 72 Bulls
team everybody
they're talking about so maybe we can be
that team that that's the 73 when the
Golden State Warriors team which would
be pretty special
obviously we're worried about Jun and
winning a championship as well but uh
the way that we're playing in the
confidence that we have and I think the
focus that we have on a nightly basis
that'll be a special thing to accomplish
it's been a fun journey I mean I don't
think I've reached my my best yet so
that's there's always room for
improvement that's how I think on a day
to day basis so I'm still working
you